this is a city divided not just by the
tigris river but also by its political
loyalties
iraq hasn't had a functioning government
for nine months
it's affected every aspect of life for
millions of people
here some of those are part of the
minority sunnis who mainly live in the
central neighborhood of the capital
known as ademiya
thirty-three-year-old mustafa assad says
his shop has been badly affected by the
recent demonstrations and political
upheaval
three quarters of people are not buying
anything here the streets are empty it
reminds me of the days of the curfew
during the pandemic it's very bad 80
percent of the businesses have been
affected
he says he stopped voting a long time
ago because he no longer believes in the
political system or its politicians
those sentiments are not confined to
those in the capital
many come from different regions to find
work in the northern province of erbil
which is home to iraq's kurdish minority
they are also feeling the effects of
what they say is an ineffective central
government in baghdad
i came here from kirkuk to work as a
taxi driver the situation in baghdad is
scary especially after nine months or so
with no government formed this has a
direct effect on the economy there are
lots of people here from baghdad also
because of the security situation there
the situation in iraq is miserable
people are afraid to buy new stuff they
don't know what will happen in the
future the country is going towards the
unknown political parties just believe
in quotas i have a family of five and
wish i could go abroad
back on the streets of the capital signs
of neglect and lack of public spending
are visible
despite the state making huge profits
through oil sales
11.5 billion dollars last month alone no
budget was passed this year
meaning most of the surplus cannot be
spent on those who need it most
this is the at the mia neighborhood in
eastern baghdad and just across the
tigris river west of here is the
predominantly shia area of kasamiya the
latest crisis is proof yet again it is
the people who suffer the most when
there's political divisions and unrest
even if it's resolved it's unlikely to
be the last for this oil rich country
dorothy jabari al jazeera baghdad